have you ever wondered what scp-168 the  sentient calculator wants most in the  world foundation researchers snapped a  photograph of scp-168 using scp-978 the  desired camera while it was sitting on  its table this was the result an  unidentified male teenager is using  scp-168 to solve several pages of  mathematical equations several textbooks  with titles such as complicated math  difficult math and math you need your  calculator for are visible sometimes the  thing we want most in the world is to  serve our true purpose to do the thing  we feel we were made for a calculator  just wants to calculate and to help  others do math maybe it will get to do  so again someday